I'm Janna and I'm a professor of physics and astronomy.
I work on where it all started.
The simplest picture of the big bang starts with nothing.
There's really nothing. There's no space. There's no time.
There's no matter. There's no energy.
It's nothing...
...but the potential to exist...
...and out of that, bursts the universe.
Time starts, space is created...
...all the matter and the energy in the universe is born at that moment,...
...and the first minute fraction of a second, the universe inflates.
And then about three minutes later, atoms begin to form.
And about five billion years later, galaxies begin to form.
One of these galaxies is about ten million years later.
A little ordinary planet forms and 14 billion years later, people evolve.
We're the last blip in the cosmic history.